[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour police judiciaire où
cette élection de farhad
vous êtes tout seul et silencieux wee a
procédé à une perquisition vous pouvez
vérifier s'il vous plaît c'est forcément
une erreur demain je rentre chez moi aux
états unis enfin plus maintenant
je vais mettre un tueur célérier votre
avocat commis d'office ce que tu sais ce
qu entre proches disent que j'ai vu
l'une vie vous reconnaissez les faits
qui vous sont reprochés non elle était
consentante ma fille a porté plainte
pour viol dans son fils au cip ça n'a
aucun sens une enquête est en cours vous
êtes placé sous contrôle judiciaire
pourrions nous retrouver en prison notre
fils non c'est sûrement une folle et
s'il a vraiment viol et que tu te rends
compte que tu vives un homme peut mentir
parce qu'il a peur parce que la réalité
de ses actes lui paraît insupportable
j'ai rien fait c'est un cauchemar vous
l'avez suivi de votre rue il m'avait dit
qu'il avait un couteau et vous a menacé
avec son couteau ce sont seulement des
questions mademoiselle vous dit qu'il a
prononcé ces mots suce-moi [ __ ] si
rapport sexuel était consenti retrouviez
au lavoir dit nous à lisbonne est ce que
vous en voulez
c'est non violence
sa vie va être foutu ou la ville qui est
clair j'avais cuba est foutue savez qui
[Musique]